each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so I think we're going to
get started uh welcome to the session on
Specialized Computing in the cloud uh we
have an excellent set of speakers and a
really exciting agenda ahead of us um
and uh for those of you who are uh not
up toate on what's been going on in the
uh field of computer architecture uh
there's been a major disruption uh
brought upon by the slowing and uh the
ending of Moore's Law and uh some in the
community have been looking at
specialization as a way to continue to
bring forth improved performance in
energy efficiency so you're going to
hear uh multiple talks today that touch
on different applications and approaches
to specialization um so each talk is
going to be about 20 minutes long uh
we're going to leave five minutes and
for Q&A so please hold your questions
till then uh and hopefully we'll have
enough time at the end to have more of
an open uh
discussion so let me introduce our first
Speaker who is um Martha Kim So Martha
uh is an assistant professor at of CES
at Columbia where she leads the arcade
lab uh Martha's research interests are
in computer architecture parallel
programming compilers and low power
Computing uh she's explored lowcost chip
Manufacturing Systems reconfigurable
communication networks and fine grain
parallel application profiling
techniques uh she currently works on
hardware and software techniques to
improve the usability of harder
accelerators as well as data Centric
accelerator design uh Martha holds a PhD
from University of Washington welcome
back and a BS and CS from Harvard uh
she's a recipient of the 2013 Rodriguez
family award and a 2013 NSF career award
thank you Eric okay um I think I just
need to and three
thanks play from
start perfect okay so thank you all for
coming um as rearch um as Eric mentioned
this afternoon I'll be presenting some
of my research group's experience in
developing A specialized Hardware
accelerator um and in our case the
domain that we were targeting was
largescale data
analytics um and since this is not
necessarily A Hardware crowd which is
usually who I find myself speaking about
these things to I thought and also I'm
the first presenter in this session on
accelerators I thought I'd take a few
moments at the start and just briefly
out line some of the kind of issues
surrounding specialization um because
these changes that we are considering
making at the uh at the low level in the
hardware um Can very very quickly
propagate up the stack in ways you may
not like
okay sorry we need to drop the
resolution I just resume y sorry no I
was right on the first
slide excellent
okay right so um as I wanted to say I
just I want to do a little quick
background and primer on kind of the
issues surrounding specialization so
there are really two questions that one
needs to consider uh the first question
is why should I even consider
specializing and the answers are right
here on these axes which is uh for power
reasons and for performance
reasons and if you um you can see from
the labels that I've just put on these
axes we're not talking about marginal
benefits we're talking about orders of
magnitude the specific numbers will
depend on what exactly you do um and
what application you're
targeting um but at one end of the
Spectrum in the upper left you know you
can take for Hardware wise a general
purpose processor and program it to
implement your function X um at the
other end of the spectrum you could
build yourself a full custom Asic which
is an application specific integrated
circuit that has been manually laid out
by Vi LSI engineers and this circuit
does nothing but x uh really well really
efficiently uh but you can't really use
it for anything else um and in you know
as you can see from where I've placed
them on the plot there are enormous
differences in terms of the efficiency
uh and performance characteristics
you'll find with these two
implementations and in between uh kind
of spanning that Gap there are other
options so for example in the third talk
you'll hear from Adrien who's going to
present uh some work that Microsoft has
done with fpgas fpgas are here in the
middle of the in the middle of the plot
and these are kind of you know fpgas
offer you a midpoint they are
programmable Hardware devices but you're
program programming them with a circuit
to do x uh so they fall somewhere
between the Spectrum and again the
numbers I've labeled here are derived
from the literature and and I'm giving
ranges because it depends on how you
design your accelerator and what sort of
workload you're targeting uh the
specific benefits you'll
see
okay so so this is why one might
consider doing it if we live up in
software in the upper left where it's
blue you know and we start to care about
power performance it's awfully tempting
to wander our way down to the lower
right okay so the second question is of
course why should I not do this um and
because we're specifically focused on
the data center in this session um I'm
going to kind of outline these issues as
they apply to Data Centers but really
any accelerator and any device of any
size would encounter these sorts of
things things so on the left hand side
I've depicted a rack of homogeneous CPUs
and um you know if you the guy
responsible for maintaining a data
center or designing it you know this
uniformity is extremely beneficial you
can quickly swap in and out parts and if
the CPU on the top Stop's working no
problem I'll send the load to the bottom
uh by contrast if you instead have a
rack where maybe at the top you've got a
few CPUs but then you've got like all
sorts of other widgets to compute XYZ
and W while your accelerators and
suddenly your only W accelerator stops
working you're kind of an Al
Lurch um so the heterogeneity there
poses you know very real and very
practical problems from the perspective
of Designing and maintaining a data
center even just regularity and form
factor is a real
issue um from the perspective of
programming one of these racks you know
we all know parallel programming is hard
but at least at least it's uniform
parallel
resources uh in contrast if you're
trying to program this guy on the right
well you might have different different
apis different ways of invoke uh
invoking the different accelerators what
if some other app is running and it
wants the accelerator so you might not
be able to get at it you know there're
you know this is for sure more Arcane
more complicated than what you'll find
in a uniform situation on the left and
then finally as far as what you can
actually compute you know on the left
hand side if the workload changes no
problem update your software run
different software you know no harm no
foul as far as the hardware is concerned
but here you've now baked into silicon
the things you're trying to compute the
functions and so if you change your mind
and say you no longer wish to compute W
but you've invested in a w you know
space in your space in your rack
designer time engineer time you know you
can no longer use this thing it's just
you know a door stop to you uh so so
they're are very real uh challenges um
and personally as an architect our
community is very comfortable and very
accustomed to focusing on things like
power and performance we can measure
them we can improve them um and so these
are these are games we play well and
frankly these reasons are the things we
really struggle with how do we we can
build good accelerators but how do we
make them readily usable um practical
and kind of practical both in a
programmatic sense and also a business
sense so these are the the the big big
issues surrounding this question of
specialization okay so so in the context
of this tension I've broken my talk into
three big sections um in the first
section I'm going to tell you about a
data analytics accelerator that we've
designed this is my lab back at Columbia
primarily the the PhD students there um
it's called The Q 100 it's a data
processing unit so kind of like a GPU
this is a
dpu um in the second section I'm going
to tell you about having designed the
first one we now have much better ideas
about what the second one should look
like and so I'd like to impart some of
those
experiences and then finally in the
third section I'll briefly highlight
some of the challenges um that we see
with respect to system integration uh
both integrating this new device under
software and integrating it in with the
hardware um and so I'll briefly touch on
those at the
end okay so so here are kind of the four
top level headlines about uh the Q 100
which is the name of our database
Processing Unit you know the the key
design feature and this is um a big
aspect of my initial architectural
motivation here is that this is a
processor that is designed to process
streams streams of data um so we're
going to interact with memory not in
terms of raw loads and stores but in
terms of bring me in that column write
out this column and so these streams
represent columns or tables that you
would find in a relational
database um we're specifically targeting
analytical queries um this is
essentially one half of the database
world you have a big pile of data how do
we comb through it and analyze it and
extract useful information there's a
whole second half uh which involves
updates and transactions you know when I
buy a pair of shoes at
do step one then step two then then step
three and a spatial one tells you do
step one here step two here and step
three here and those are all independent
but spatially
parallelized okay so working from the
top down um here's just a fly over how
of how this device works so say you have
some query and I'm showing one here in
SQL that um what's it doing ah it's
Computing a quarterly sales report for
the the total
sales
um so this the query at the top there
can now be boiled down into an execution
plan that we're expressing here as a
graph um and in this plan the nodes in
the graph represent operations such as
an aggregate or a column select and the
edges between them represent
dependencies and these edges have data
streaming along them so it's not a bite
or a word or a struct it's a column from
a table
um and as far as constructing this plan
you can do it either manually or uh
compile down um we've done both and um
our manual plans are a little better
than the comp the compiler output but
they're okay um and if and if your
intuition is that this is an important
step you're actually absolutely right
this planning stage is is a big
determinant of your quality of
result okay so then given a plan we need
to map it to a particular Q100 device
and so the hardware itself which I've
depicted here on the right it contains
some finite set of of resources so kind
of surrounding that interconnect up
there you'll see there are two diamonds
and three uh trapezoids and whatnot and
that depicts I have two of The Diamond
tiles and three of the circles and
whatnot and my plan may require more
tiles than I have and so what we're
going to do is we're going to schedule
the plan onto the available resources um
this is a fairly standard scheduling
problem where given a
fixed given a fixed set of
resources and respecting the
dependencies in the plan we're going to
say all right given what I have I can do
that whole blue chunk of work first then
in the next time step I can take the
next
chunk and then finally it's going to
take me onethird step to complete the
rest of my plan so this is a simple
temporal scheduling
operation and then the last step is to
go execute this plan so the inputs
reside in memory we stream in the
initial data and bring it into the first
operator and I haven't depicted it here
simply because the figure would be a
mess but these operators to the extent
there are dependencies between them that
data streams directly Point too on chip
and eventually once the blue work is
done there's some Edge in that plan that
was cut between the blue and and the red
The Next Step that results needs to be
spilled back out to memory and then we
just repeat this process step by step so
you know we suck that result back in
comput it in the red
stage and spill it again and then the
third step
happens um and so essentially you read
from memory compute and spill until you
have completed your query plan with the
available resources and so immediately
here there's this tradeoff that you can
see that the more resources I put down
the fewer spills I will incur and this
is part of the design space that we've
explored
Lord okay so I want to be a little more
concrete about these tiles because this
turns out to be important when I go to
explain what we want to do next um so
bear with me it's going to be at the at
the risk of giving you too much detail I
feel I need to share this so I'm going
to start with a very very simple tile
and then I'll show you the one that
really matters um so this is a very this
is our simplest tile it's called the
Boolean generator it's just a comparator
and all it does is take in two streams
of data here in zero and in one and you
know in a relational system these things
correspond it will do some comparison as
dictated by the configuration
information up at the top and then it
will spit out just essentially one bit
per comparison result say that one
failed that one passed that one failed
that one passed so tiny little bite of
analys or a bit of
analysis and then based on that
predicate you might in fact almost
always we take this Boolean predicate
and use it in conjunction with a second
tile such as a column filter where using
that predicate and some other data it
might be a third column it might be one
of the same match them up and
selectively
output those for which the comparison
succeeded so this is you know your basic
wear claw and SQL you can string
together a bunch of bullens and and do
this
filtering okay so that that's a pretty
simple TI to wrap your head around um
there are more complicated ones uh so so
I want to introduce a tile that does
performs the range partitioning
operation so for those who aren't
familiar range partitioning or actually
just partitioning in general is a pretty
common operation in databases where you
take a big table um and because it's so
big it or It's associated metadata um
just won't fit in Cache so in order to
process it more efficiently what you do
is first partition it into smaller
tables and then process each of those
partitions you know in parallel or even
in series but with better cache locality
so so range partitioning is a specific
flavor of partitioning where we're going
to partition the key space or the domain
of keys into particular ranges so if
that's my big input table on the left
there I have a number of splitter values
uh which here I've just for the example
said 10 20 and 30 and those are my cut
points and then what I want to do is
break the big table into smaller tables
based on the values of the keys and how
they correspond to the
Splitters okay so that's what we want to
compute I'm now going to show you the
tile that does
this okay so so using kind of the visual
language of the previous tile I have
coming in on the left my input table so
you can think of it as a key column plus
some other data basically payload that I
want to keep associated with the key and
what I want to have coming out here on
the bottom are each of my output
partitions
um and kind of configured in at the top
are the splitter values and again um you
know I'm depicting three but these are
typically much higher fan out
partitions so if you were to look inside
this tile uh you'd see a circuit sort of
like this um if you kind of squint at it
and pick out these registers you're
going to find that it operates in a
pipeline so I have a little example I
think it's this it's the same one um so
my splitter values get stuck in
registers that I've shown up at the top
there 10 20 and 30 and then say I have a
record with the key value 15 that comes
in I'm not differentiating key from
payload because they kind of just travel
and lock step anyway so 15 comes in
it'll be compared with 10 um it's not
smaller than 10 and so it will just
advance in the pipeline um it is smaller
than 20 and so at this point this kind
of smaller than condition will be found
to be true and this record will be you
know kind of dropped out of the conveyor
belt at the appropriate partition and so
just think of like a penko machine with
things rolling along and falling out as
as
appropriate okay so so this is how this
tile operates and um we have um I'm
showing you this because I would like to
refer back to it in a little
bit okay so we have 11 such tiles so I
showed you the bul genen and I showed
you the
partitioner um and here what I'm
plotting is if you were to inspect the
circuit for each of those tiles so each
of these functions you'd find that they
vary of course they all do different
things so here we see that they all have
different critical paths but this
resource imbalance is is really
problematic what it tells us is that you
know that my partitioner is setting my
critical path and that call column
filter guy that I showed you earlier
he's got you know 80% of the clock cycle
where he's just idle he's not doing any
useful work so I have a slight imbalance
in terms of how I'm using at a very very
fine grin that clock Cycles this is
another thing we're going to come back
and fix in version
two um and if I were to look at the area
and power consumption of the tiles I'd
see similar sorts of issues where some
are big and some are small um and having
dedicated say a large chunk of area to
my partitioner if I have a query that
doesn't require partitioning there's
nothing I can do with this current
design to recover those resources I've
spent them on partitioning if I don't
happen to need
partitioning um you know I just can't
get any value from
them okay so to so to quickly kind of
close the loop on the q00 I'm happy to
discuss the designs and the issues
surrounding this thing uh much more
offline um in order to kind of compose
an entire accelerator you introduce some
mix of these tiles and so we looked at a
design space um you wire them together
um and then you kind of see how fast
queries you care about run so in this
case I've plotted here power versus or
sorry runtime versus Power um of a
common analytic Benchmark suite and you
can see you know there are trade-offs to
be had um and so picking three out kind
of the lowest power design the highest
performance design and some kind of more
balanced design on the parade of
Frontier um we can take those three
specific designs and and compare them to
actual
software um and just briefly you know
here's kind of relative energy relative
power relative runtime this is relative
to um the same software running on modb
it's an open source uh column oriented
dbms um you know it compares favorably
and another kind of nice experiment that
we did that I found interesting was that
if you say hey I designed this chip with
one particular data size in mind and
then I made the data 100 times bigger
and tried to shove you know 100 times
the data through the chip of the
original size what happens we see that
you know we do take a hit on the runtime
you know this is a the same uh circuitry
trying to turn through a 100 times the
data volume it's going to take longer
however the the relative power and
energy still hold up pretty well which
we thought was a an promising uh
effect okay so I started the
presentation talking about um you know
the wise and wi's not why Nots of
accelerators um and hinting at this
notion of there are kind of good and bad
ways to go about doing this uh so I want
to highlight a few of the things that we
would do differently next
time um so briefly these 11 tiles that
I've just summarized they're all
unitaskers yet if you actually look at
the circuitry under the covers there's a
lot of commonality amongst them um and
so this is what we would like to exploit
to have a more generic notion of
resource that can we can better shape
through our queries so let me explain
exactly what I mean so here's that
partitioner again what I had was
stationary Red Data my splitter values I
put in at the top and then I had the
stream of blue data that marches along
and is alternately at each stage the
blue record either advances or falls out
based on the output of some
comparison so if you think about a
different operation uh for example a
merge where you have two ordered streams
and you want to merge them again in
order um I'm still showing the harp
circuitry but I've kind of scribbled
colored lines over it think of it as a
red and a blue stream they're both
advancing and based on the comparisons
one advances and one holds and so
they'll alternately block until you get
from the two input streams which now
move a single merged output stream and
in this scenario we're not using any of
the vertical options but again you have
the same sorts of things
comparing corresponding elements and
then conditionally advancing based on
the result of that comparison and you're
also doing a little routing in this case
we're going straight with the
partitioner we had the option of turning
right to go
downwards um and you can even kind of
keep doing this to more complicated
operations so just to throw out you know
one that was fairly new to me as a non-
database person there's this thing
called a nested block Loop join where
you essentially want to do an all to-
all comparison amongst two tables and
you can even do that with actually very
very similar Hardware where you to
compare all red records to all blue
records you stream in a chunk of the red
table as many as can fit in your
available Hardware then you stream by
the entire Blue Table and whenever the
join condition
matches you bring down here the
combination and then again you need to
stream in The Next Step you know the
next chunk of the red table and you
repeat this process until all records in
red have been compared using the the
filter to all records in
blue okay so those are just three quick
sketches of how these sorts of resources
can be kind of programmatically combined
to execute analytic
operations so for dpu 2.0 we would do
something that looks more like this say
hey look take each of those pipeline
stages as its own homogeneous
programmable
tile and array them not only in vert uh
sorry horizontal pipeline lines but
vertical columns and then what we've
really done is matched together the
storage of those buffers which I've
depicted as red and blue the routing
options which again is conditionally
based on various protocols and compar
you know data comparisons and then of
course some combinational Logic for for
those comparisons which I haven't even
drawn in this
picture um and so what you find is that
we have now homogeneous resources so I'm
hoping this will yield better resource
use usage if I have a join heavy query
that requires no merging I don't have to
program any of these guys to do the
merge
protocol um whereas if I have the
inverse I can handle that as well with
the same
resources um so we're hoping for to see
better
utilization similarly the interconnect
here I didn't highlight this with the
old design but this is a very regular
point-to-point interconnect so we've got
lots of little short local Liars uh
where the routing is kind of spread
throughout these little programming
protocols
um and then I already mentioned the
unification of the buffering and the
routing okay so um I'm because I can see
I'm I'm running low on time I'm just
going to tell you the two things that I
was going to tell you um and if anyone
would like to discuss this further
offline um I'll stick around so I I
wanted to highlight a few of the issues
surrounding integrating an accelerator
into a general purpose system because
really you know the things we do level
of the hardware can very quickly become
you know some or many programmers
problems uh you know the way we
integrate the accelerator with the CPU
determines the dispatch method which
determines how long it takes to send a
chunk of work over to the accelerator
which in turn determines how much work
how big chunks how small chunk you can
afford to send over there um and so very
quickly this affects much much higher
level design
decisions so there are two things that
we think are promising and I'm just
going to tell you what they are
so the first relates to this data
oriented Excel um analytics uh which
is you know we found it very beneficial
to exploit existing software interfaces
higher level interfaces so in this case
in the database World there are
dbms's and there is SQL so there is a
standard language and there are certain
tools software runtime systems that can
help hide these potentially unwelcome
Hardware changes um so this is a picture
of our compiler which I won't go into
and then the second is um in the realm
of of unifying accelerators and CPUs in
a single address space this just makes
programming easier you don't have to
Marshall data on and off um but you need
to introduce some Hardware to do that
and we've done some experiments that
indicate that you know if you naively
introduce address translation Hardware
into an accelerator you're going to give
up all your performance benefits uh so
this can be done but there again right
and wrong ways to do it um but we think
this is an important thing to kind of
facilitate the adoption of Hardware
accelerators um so with that I will um I
will close um and just return to the
summary slide and uh I'll take any
questions do I have time yep so let's
thank our speaker
first so we have time for maybe one or
two questions while our next Speaker
gets set
up oh and please wait until the mic gets
to you it's on its
way
Sor uh I'm just curious does your sort
tile uh use the partition
tile yes that's part of the reason that
we actually chose to implement the range
partitioning flavor of partitioning okay
is that um the sort I wouldn't say it
uses the partition tile but it certainly
depends on it so if you have you need to
sort a large body of data that's larger
say than what can fit in the sort tiles
buffers you need to in this initial
design partition down until it can fit
and range partitioning has the followup
question is how come your sort takes a
smaller amount of time than your
partitioning
Tire oh oh that the the the charts I
shed um that's not uh execution time
that's critical path length so it's more
a property of the circuit than the yeah
than the
operator so I think I think we should
probably move on to the next speaker but
do you have more questions questions
please talk to Martha thank her
again
so um our next speaker is Tom uh Tom
wines he's an associate professor of
csse uh University of Michigan
specializing in computer architecture
his prior research includes memory
streaming for commercial server
Applications store weight free
multi-processor memory systems memory
disaggregation and rigorous sampling
based performance evaluation
methodologies uh Tom is currently
looking at computational sprinting data
center architecture energy efficient
server design and multicore
multiprocessor memory systems Tom
received the NSF career award in 2009
and previously was a software developer
at the American power conversion where
he worked on data center thermal
topology estimation uh he holds a PhD
from carnegi uh melon
University thanks Eric uh thanks
everybody uh for coming so I'm going to
tell you guys about uh thin servers with
smart pipes uh which is sort of my first
foray along with my students and a whole
bunch of collaborators uh uh to think
about how we can use sort of
accelerators and S so technology in this
sort of wonderful landscape of trying to
integrate different pieces uh to improve
Energy Efficiency in the data center uh
so you know the interesting anecdote
about this particular uh piece of work
is you can see from the set of
co-authors that uh we have a pretty
diverse set of companies involved on
this particular paper uh so shortly
after we published this a bunch of
reporters called looking for a
conspiracy theory why were all these
companies ined together sadly there is
there is no conspiracy it's just sort of
the happen stance of of uh where people
have moved around um so the uh the sort
of taking off point for for this line of
work is that there had been uh repeated
efforts over the last few years to try
to implement data center applications
with more energy efficient processors
processors of the kind that we'd have in
sort of our cell phones and embedded
systems you know let's take something
like an arm core maybe something more
powerful in an arm core that is has less
stuff but is more energy efficient or at
least draws less power than the big
beefy Big Iron cores that we put in
servers and so it's been pretty hard to
do this because it's been pretty hard to
get good enough performance uh and sort
of the question is if we can find a lot
of what those processors are spending
their time executing and offload that to
some bit of hardware on the side maybe
the work that's left over that's more
complicated that would be very difficult
to cast in Hardware
can be uh executed on one of these you
know much more lower power cores that we
can then integrate at much greater
density and so on uh and sort of the
second taking off point for this uh
project is that when you think about
sort of data center applications which
are large distributed systems where
these different you know clients and
servers are sort of talking to each
other over the network mcash D is about
as simple as it gets right this thing is
pretty dumb it doesn't do anything it
does a key value lookup and returns you
know one packet over the network in
response to request there's no
coordination if we can't do it here
we're certainly not going to uh uh you
know be able to accelerate many other
kinds of very complicated uh distributed
stores and so uh uh it it's nice because
there's really just 10,000 lines of code
how hard can it be uh so so with that
let me uh let me step back and give just
a little bit more introduction uh to you
know why why would this be an important
thing to think about and key value
caching layers not necessarily MCD but
other kinds of key value caching layers
really are pervasive in large scale
internet services uh so MCD is one
particular open- Source uh piece of
software that uh uh we know at least
Facebook uses some variant of internally
and it really is key to them being able
to scale to the amount of traffic that
they support so it's really critical for
these workloads where you want to get
interactive access uh to data with low
latency and very high throughput and uh
one of the nice aspects of very simple
key value stores is that if your number
of customers grows because you have a
great idea and your web service is
taking off uh and sort of you have to
start caching more data you can
organically scale up the size of the
cach to keep up with the amount of data
that's being stored and through some
simple tricks like consistent hashing
and so on you can make it relatively
easy to manage and increase the size of
a a software pool a cache pool uh now
the because these things have grown
gically over time uh there's also sort
of been incremental software refinement
really targeting the kind of commodity
servers sort of general purpose high-end
servers that run all sorts of things uh
in these data centers and so there might
be some opportunities on the table to
sort of rethink and do things completely
differently uh than uh we've arrived at
just through this incremental refinement
uh another key aspect of this kind of
workload is that we actually care quite
a bit about the performance of an
individual server because since any
client may end up talking to any one of
of these mcash servers that happens to
be responsible for a particular key
value pair uh that one server if it
becomes busy could become the bottleneck
right or it could be the thing that
limits the overall performance of my web
service and at the same time because I
don't want to uh ultimately I'm limited
by the power capacity of my data center
uh uh I would like it to be power
efficient that is I want this to be
quite good from a peak power perspective
as I grow these pools and so the
question that we were really posing is
is this approach of you know kind of the
current latest optimized variant of the
open source software running on a
commodity server efficient and how do
things compare when I consider the sort
of Big Iron best thing that Intel will
sell me to something that's much more
modest but perhaps more power efficient
server uh Peak power efficient server
something like an Intel atom class
processor
okay and so the first step in trying to
figure out what should this accelerator
do is we took a look at at what is what
does this workload look like when you
run it on these sort of two ends of the
processor spectrum and what we
discovered is that neither of these
things was actually particularly good if
we're trying to optimize the efficiency
of a key value cache uh uh so
surprisingly perhaps despite the
Simplicity of the workload uh the
execution time of this is dominated by
lots and lots of stuff that the
operating system is doing on behalf of
the mcash and in particular you're
spending a lot of time
pushing packets in and out of the
network interface and it turns out that
the the code paths to operate a
networking stack are actually quite long
uh and so when we put this on a high-end
server we get very good performance but
in fact we reveal some inefficiencies
some of these really high-end components
of the processor that are designed to do
really well on a scientific application
are actually buying me very little when
I'm running through this giant very IO
intensive code path of the networking
stack and in particular as I'll show you
with a couple of results we find that
all of the investment that computer
Architects have been have made into
fetching instructions really well you
know things like large instruction
caches and very sophisticated Branch
predictors actually do a really horrible
job on this particular workload and so
the net result is that all of that
energy that you're investing in those
structures really is wasted uh similarly
these servers have giant caches to store
sort of huge data sents for for example
database workloads but because there is
so little locality in the actual data uh
that's being served by the key value
store you're getting very little return
on the substantial amount of Chip area
that's invested in these large caches
now if we go to the other end of the
spectrum and try to make a super simple
processor work uh we'll find that
relative to what I save in Peak power or
what I might be able to gain in energy
efficiency I'm simply giving too much
performance up when you stress something
like an Intel atom trying to run uh uh
the networking stack at high performance
as load goes up the the processor simply
Falls over it's unable to keep up and in
fact you end up with worse drastically
worse Energy Efficiency than the big
iron machine simply because performance
has dropped so much and so sort of the
the the stepping off point here is that
both extremes of the commodity
architecture space are really ill suited
for handling lots and lots of small
Network packets and perhaps There's an
opportunity to do something different
and so uh so the the approach that we
took here is to sort of go back to
computer architect cure 101 to you know
the Hennessy and Patterson textbook make
the common case fast and so the common
case for the vast majority though not
all mcash D workloads is that you spend
most of your time doing gets you're
mostly reading keys out of the cache uh
so for example uh Facebook reported that
you know sort of averaged over a bunch
of the different workloads uh 30 to1
ratio of gets to sets uh is typical for
some of their uses of
MCD um so the idea with thin servers
with smart pipes is to try to get all of
the work of processing gets off of the
processor and into a specialized
pipeline so let's simplify that problem
as much as we can so with a relatively
simple piece of Hardware we can interact
directly with the network and actually
execute get requests without invoking a
single instruction on the processor uh
so you know that means we going to need
to deal with the networking stack packet
deci uh decipher generating responses
and also managing the actual data
structure that allows us to locate
values from keys but at the same time it
would be quite difficult to implement
the entire MCD software entirely in
hardware and so we defer more
complicated things like for example
managing memory and deciding exactly
where to allocate objects or managing
the replacement policy in the cache so
that we do something that's perhaps an
approximation of least recently used
these things we defer to software and
hopefully we've taken enough load that
now a much simpler processor can
actually keep up with demand um so so
this is sort of what we've demonstrated
in in uh uh sort of an fpga based
prototype and uh you know if you project
what this would look like in a platform
where you have an fpga integrated with a
processor something like a zinc or maybe
something with a little beefier
processor than a zinc uh uh we project a
performance per wat advantage of 6X over
the high-end server and 16x over the the
first generation atom that we measured
here uh and that's already sort of a
wind that's in the ballpark of of worth
considering uh uh perhaps you know
deploying several thousand of these
things to replace a MCD
pool so uh so with that I'll briefly uh
uh give you some you know background on
MCD in case you've never seen it before
uh and then I'll take you through some
of the insights we gained from this
characterization study and then just
show you a couple of pictures sort of
block diagrams for what were the key
decisions we made in this relatively
simple uh uh offload engine for get
requests uh and then I'll
conclude so um so I've sort of said some
of this already but a typical
architecture for uh a web service is
that you'll have some kind of stateless
presentation layer or front end that's
actually executing uh the the you know
terminating the connection to the uh
external user and you know running the
web server code and so on so you know in
the case of of Facebook it's actually
the entire me uh the entire Facebook
application runs stateless in these web
servers and you have a third layer down
here a database layer or some kind of
storage layer which is the ultimate
durable store for all of the data that
gets written or updated by web server
requests and if we simply had the web
servers talk directly to the databases
we'd have an extremely expensive
solution because the amount of code you
need to run to make stuff durable and
and reliable and so on is is quite uh uh
quite large and so we'd either need a
heck of a lot of database servers or
perhaps we wouldn't be able to keep up
with the massive amount of throughput
that all these web servers can generate
and so since most of our requests are
read reads we can improve the overall uh
cost effectiveness of the system by
introducing these caching layers in
between where the mcache can respond
much faster respond with much higher uh
throughput per dollar and most of our
traffic will get served by these
specialized mcash pools for various
applications uh and only rights need to
all be reflected all the way back to the
database um and so the details on how
you do this of course differ and the
real pictures are much more complicated
but this is the basic idea of why memc
is a cost win for a lot of web services
and so the what we want to understand is
how can we design some kind of you know
more Peak power efficient or energy
efficient uh system if really all it has
to do is M cach and it doesn't ever have
to run anything
else and really what we discovered in
measuring these existing service is that
you get really poor performance for
serving very small objects which is a
very common case out of these M caches
so I'm showing you two graphs here uh
the first graph over here the horizontal
axis on both graphs is object size okay
uh so what is the size of the thing that
we're getting out of MD the vertical
axis here is throughput so higher is
better and over on this part of the
graph uh uh you can see that we can
basically hit theoretical throughput in
practice right basically we're limited
by the bandwidth of the network there's
really nothing else you can do this is
the best case scenario we're sending
data everything's wonderful however as
the object size get smaller and smaller
at some point the uh uh actual achieved
bandwidth on a real system Falls
drastically short of what you would
project if you just took the data size
and divided it by the serialization
delay of writing it to the network and
what's going on here is that the CPU is
no longer able to keep up to execute the
networking code to get the packets out
fast enough it's simply falling short on
the number of IO operations per second
that need to be executed to actually
curate all of these packets and so you
see our CPU here the single CPU that's
pushing this traffic is pegged at 100%
for any object size that gets sort of
close to that uh uh 64 128 256 byte
limit
uh and so the CPU is the bottleneck but
why what in God's name is it
doing so we basically took you know
various uh uh we wanted to understand
what the hardware was doing what the
processor was doing by doing load tests
with sort of traffic that was designed
to represent various Facebook like use
cases and really ask what is the what is
the microarchitecture doing what is the
thing that's limiting instruction
throughput uh and also what is this
interaction with the Nick what is going
on and how can we uh improve the
interaction between the CPU and the Nick
and so we've looked at sort of two
classes of processors as I said before
and these things are very different
they're so the the frequency is much
higher in the server Class part which is
the Zeon over here has much more caching
it has a much more capable memory
interface that's capable of higher
bandwidth and with both of these two
servers we've also tried a variety of
different networking Hardware to
understand how much can a better IO
interface and a better network interface
buy you and how does that compare to for
example the alternative of having a
faster
processor uh so I've sort of already uh
told you at the beginning uh the main
results but relative to the theoretical
Peak Performance that you could get out
of a Zeon or an atom uh uh these
workloads use the microarchitecture very
inefficiently so the graph that I'm
showing you here the vertical axis is
the number of clock Cycles the average
instruction takes to execute so this is
a graph where lower is better and for
the Zeon processor in theory if we were
pushing the processor completely to the
metal you know running some kind of uh
scientific application that has lots and
lots of parilis available uh we could
get well under one clock per instruction
we could do four or five instructions on
average every single clock tick uh and
yet as you can see here we're you know a
factor of five to 10 worse in terms of
using the theoretical capability of the
uh the microarchitecture and we're
somewhere between a factor of two and
four worse than the typical applications
that people in the computer architecture
Community study you know things like
scientific Computing applications which
tend to use the microarchitecture quite
well um so you know we're very far away
from what theoretically could be going
on so why are instructions taking two to
eight Cycles you know where where is all
this time being lost and uh uh to our
surprise what we discovered when we
actually looked at the various stall
sources is that the largest bottleneck
and the one that stood out as most
unexpected was instruction cache
performance that is the the structures
in the processor that uh are trying to
accelerate instruction Supply uh so uh
instruction translation instruction cach
and also Branch prediction and we're
surprised at this because the code is so
small what in God's name is MCD doing uh
and the reality is that it's the the
kernel and the massive bloat of the
tcpip stack in other aspects so things
like uh uh locking and memory management
that put tremendous pressure on these uh
Hardware structures and so we end up
seeing
uh these structures overwhelmed when we
compare them to again the kind of
desktop and Engineering applications
that the architecture Community is so
fond of of having bar graphs of in all
of our
papers
uh so uh uh so this is sort of something
that we'd like to address and the way to
do it is to get rid of some of these
instructions let's not run through these
giant code paths let's try to move some
of these very long code paths to the
accelerator in the common case the
second uh thing that we did in this
characterization study was take a look
at how much better can we make things if
we use a smarter network interface if we
use a better Nick a more capable Nick
Nicks with features like interrupt
coalescing or receiver side scaling
where the Nick will actually take pains
to steer uh TCP flows to particular
processors or to reduce the frequency
with which they send interrupts to the
processors uh uh and so we started sort
of with the cheapest Nick you could find
uh uh some commodity garbage that
probably came from eBay or something uh
uh and then we sort of spent money on
what's sort of the best state-of-the-art
Nick we could buy uh and we also asked
the question you know is it bandwidth or
is it really these uh uh interface
features of the network interface that
improve performance and so in some cases
for workloads where messages are large
like in this image preview and and Wiki
serving uh application bandwidth in fact
helps a lot so these two rightmost bars
here we went from a 1 gbit to a 10 gabit
ethernet card and unsurprisingly
performance goes up drastically if
you're really limited by the uh
serialist a delay of the link however
what again was somewhat of a surprise to
us initially although is obvious in
retrospect is that uh uh for very small
objects in particular these two
workloads over here micro blogging and
our and our simple fixed fixed object
size workload uh uh they're super
sensitive to how efficiently the Nick
interacts with the CPU and how often it
interrupts the CPU and simply taking
fewer trips through the software stack
leads to somewhere between factor of two
and factor of three performance
increases
so what we took away from this is tight
integration with the network and trying
to get the processor out of that
interaction path uh is a potential win
so so with these observations then we
you know propos this idea thin servers
with smart pipes so by making the pipe
smarter by being able to talk directly
to the network without software
intervention perhaps we can reduce the
load on the processor to the point where
a much thinner processor is able to keep
up with the remaining work uh so we take
advantage
trying to get uh uh rid of these
frequent network interface uh uh
interactions taking advantage of the
fact that get requests dominate so as
long as we can get the gets out of the
way there isn't all that much left and
we propos this s so architecture that
takes the low power core and integrates
this uh accelerator pipeline for for
processing get requests um so I'll just
show you a couple of quick pictures
these are sort of block diagram cartoons
of how this thing works but I'll try to
highlight very briefly some of what we
thought are sort of the important
reusable ideas that might apply to some
other kind of accelerator uh so this is
just sort of a system block diagram uh
there's nothing super surprising here
this is sort of any so might look
something like this but a key decision
here is that you see we have this this
mcash accelerator this is the custom
piece of Hardware that we're sticking on
the side and modeling in our fpga speak
directly to the Nick and I'll show you
how that interaction works and another
key design decision is that uh we have a
shared system mmu that allows the mcache
accelerator to translate main memory and
actually access uh uh main memory in
concert with the software that's
executing on the CPU so basically
virtual memory is shared between the
accelerator and the CPU and this is
again you know that's not rocket science
this is something that you can do with
Anu architecture uh um that various
vendors have available today so if we
zoom into that mcash accelerator block
and try to understand uh sort of that
Arrow of how the Nick talks to the
accelerator so this diagram Zooms in a
little bit uh the top part of this
uh uh diagram is sort of a couple of
blocks that you have in a fairly
conventional network interface and the
bottom half is the accelerator the new
widgets that we've added on the side and
so over here uh we have the interface to
the actual Network so you have your
physical layer and uh uh sort of the
first levels of error checking and so on
and in a conventional Nick there's this
component called the flow affiniti which
is a thing that's deciding which CPU
should I send the interrupt to for this
particular flow exactly which receive Q
should the packet get directed to
uh with the objective of trying to get
sort of the same flows to go to the same
CPUs over uh over and over again to
improve locality so this is the point
where we hook into the system and we
have the flow affiniti uh identify
packets that are mcash get requests and
there we used a cheap trick we send the
get requests over UDP and so all UDP
packets are destined for our accelerator
all TCP packets go through the normal
processing Pipeline and we dump them
down to our uh accelerator over here a
UDP offload engine handles the actual
UDP protocol which is fairly simple
because you don't have to remember a lot
of stuff like you do with more
complicated Network protocols we go
through a packet decipher layer which
figures out is this a well formed get
request and what is the key and what is
the fingerprint to the key and what am I
looking for we go through a h a hardware
hash lookup step which I'll show you one
more slide on uh which actually
determines whether the key is present
and finds the value in memory and then
uh uh you know we do dma to assemble the
response packet and then shove that back
into the transmit buffer directly in the
nick all without any interaction
from the processor okay uh for the
common
case so let me uh uh uh briefly zoom in
on sort of how does this hash lookup
work and what is the what is the split
and responsibility between software and
Hardware uh so the idea again is simply
to make the common case fast and so we
want a very simple Hardware hash table
that's very easy to implement uh however
we we want to avoid synchronization
overheads between software and hardware
and the software is going to be
responsible for actually inserting new
objects into the key value store so uh
the hardware uses uh uh some ideas sort
of that come from things like cuckoo
hash tables where you can get very very
good load Factor very high storage
density on a hash table by actually
having multiple alternative locations
that a key could hash uh and in addition
to having sort of four locations that
will'll look up in parallel uh because
this itself can still fill up we have
sort of a a uh a associative lookup
memory that handles overflows beyond
that so the hardware is basically going
to look in four spots and look at its
overflow buffer and if it can't find the
object there well then it must not be in
the key Value Store uh software is
responsible for for dealing with the
memory allocation of actually
efficiently packing all of these objects
in memory and maintaining lru and so on
and so here we have a a fairly standard
memory allocator it's a slab allocator
and the key idea is that software does
not directly manipulate the the
hashtable data structure that's actually
used in lookups instead to avoid any
need for synchronization the software
actually delegates the responsibility of
maintaining the hash table the hardware
it'll insert requests to change to
insert keys and remove keys from the
hash table into the hardware Pipeline
and so the the hash table is in fact
touched only by
Hardware so I think the takeaway from
this is not the details of this
particular design you know this is just
you know we had a relatively simple
problem and we solved it with relatively
straightforward mechanisms I think the
principle to take away is uh uh the to
to think about this Hardware versus
software complexity partitioning and to
think about issues like synchronization
between the hardware accelerator and the
the software to find a very simple
interface and here this the interface is
extremely simple uh it's the software
simply asks the hardware to to make some
very small changes to the the hash table
as
needed so uh so our evaluation here is a
little bit of a sort of a Frankenstein
evaluation since we we actually don't
have a full implementation of the entire
system uh but we have measured the
accelerator component the actual things
serving get requests uh via UDP and uh
uh from there you'll have to take some
of the power numbers with a little bit
of a grain of salt but they're projected
based on looking at similar s so systems
and figuring out what would the
processor be how much power would the
actual uh accelerator component use how
much power would the networking use the
the numbers on the Zeon and the atom are
actual real measured uh power and
performance numbers but so through the
lens of the limitations of sort of uh
spreadsheet analysis of power uh uh we
still are well over an order of man
itude uh more efficient uh in terms of
operations per watt or performance per
watt uh and so you know in order of
magnitude even with sort of the
approximations here uh even if we give
some of that back we're still doing
quite a bit better and yet still
maintaining a quite respectable Peak
Performance from one particular uh uh
mcash server relative to what the server
what the real servers can uh uh
accomplish so uh so let me just briefly
conclude uh uh so as I've sort of said
you know mcash D there's a lot of MCD
servers in the world it is probably
worth thinking about how to make it more
efficient perhaps not it's unclear that
a hardware accelerator is the way to go
but there are enough of these things
that if you can find a way to make them
single digigit percent more efficient
you're still saving lots and lots of
money for some big companies uh and we
discovered that uh frequent Network
interaction really was a key performance
bottom lck and so finding a way to get
the common case uh software path out of
the way uh was a good way to improv
performance uh and so you know we've
we've demonstrated this Hardware
approach to get gets to execute
completely in Hardware uh but more
broadly you know the from here one of
the one of the things that I've taken
away from this is that uh uh you really
want to do compute intensive stuff in
accelerators and this is not a
particularly compute intensive operation
now the tcpip stack I guess has a fair
bit of code and so there was a lot of
value in getting it out of the way but
really looking forward I don't think I
would pick mcash D again as the workload
to focus on uh I think I'm much more
excited now about accelerators for media
intensive processing you know you have
lots of bits you have to do uh some kind
of streaming operation over lots and
lots of bits uh or things like machine
learning and inference that are really
becoming increasingly important right
doing these massive models like for
example you're going to hear about in
the next talk where there's lots of
number crunching that needs to go on
that number crunching is drastically
more efficient when you drop down a
custom piece of Hardware than when you
implement it with something like a a
really intensive outof order processor
uh and so uh you know with that I think
uh you know I'll take any questions you
have and hopefully that's a good setup
for what Adrian's going to tell you next
on how you can really do machine machine
inference very well uh with fpga
acceleration let's thank our
speaker so we have time for questions
just a few minutes but please wait for
the
mic Jim so Tom um if the tcpip staff is
the problem isn't the solution to fix
the TCP IP stack rather than build this
special purpose piece of Hardware to
work around it yeah so I mean uh uh so I
agree the tcpip stack definitely needs
fixing it has gotten better so these
measurements were done you know a couple
years ago and I think a lot of effort
has been invested but you can't do
better than making it go to zero so here
we've sort of taken it completely uh
completely out of the picture uh uh and
I mean right but but but the the work
that you allude to has basically
basically reduce the overhead of tcpip
so it's at least for MCD it's not on the
critical path anymore and you can't do
better because you can saturate the 10
gig E Yeah so that I think that'll help
a lot with the uh sort of the the
instruction cache issues we're seeing
and and and uh that would no longer be
the bottom however it's still 97% of
your your your traffic is these get
requests and the question that remains
is even if I make tcpip faster can a
wimpier core keep up executing the the
the mcash software execu TCP IP or will
it hit some other bottleneck and if it's
still hitting another bottleneck then I
can't go down to this really cheap core
that I'd like to be able to use so by
moving this common case completely into
Hardware now I'm left with much less
work to be done on the general purpose
processor and now a wimpier processor
will be able to keep up so the question
is sort of do my software optimizations
get me to the point where I can get away
with the processor as wimpy as I'd like
or not and I I don't have an answer to
that question we'd have to go back and
measure again with the latest mcash D
and the latest changes in the Linux
kernel for tcpip to figure out just how
wimpy can I get and still keep up let's
take just one more question over
there I had
two okay um quick follow on to last one
just for clarification I had the same
question about TCP been I I thought a
lot of people use actually UDP forgets
and it seemed like you in fact used UDP
forgets I was a little confused what
your analysis of then sh TCP locking was
so so we did measure the performance
change from just switching to TCP to UDP
uh and it's 10% you get 10% better okay
uh uh so I guess when I say TCP stack I
should probably more generically say the
networking parts of the kernel so so my
real question was um I I've seen also
some other work who basically try to
replace the get path with RDMA and so
I'm wondering if you could it sound like
kind of you reconstructed the whole
whole RDMA thing so I was wondering if
you could kind of compare to these
things yeah so I mean that I think yeah
so there's I think some work out of Ohio
that demonstrates uh RDMA based mkd and
you get drastic improvements uh and so I
think that's actually a very exciting
direction to go I think uh uh why given
RDMA is kind of mature why not I mean
why why do you go this direction rather
than just asking about RDMA it's it's
quite expensive I think that's the
that's that's the the one downside of
the networking Hardware you require for
RDMA relative to sort
of okay but yeah I think that makes
sense all right let's thank the speaker
again
okay so our last speaker of this session
is Adrian Caulfield uh Adrian joined
Microsoft research in July
2013 uh focusing on using reconfigurable
Computing to accelerate large scale uh
data center uh workloads he holds a ba
in CS from University of Washington
Seattle uh in Ms and Cs and a PhD in
computer engineering from University of
California San Diego his dissertation
focused on the development and
optimization of solid state discs
targeting Emer emerging memory
Technologies such as phase change memory
and spin torque transfer mams he also
worked extensively with flash memory
during his time at UCSD great thank you
um so I'd like to talk to you today
about uh reconfigurable fabric that
we've been building here at Microsoft
for accelerating large scale data center
Services um this is work that's been
done by a large number of us here at
Microsoft and uh but basically led by
Doug burer and Derek Chu and you can
imagine at a company like Microsoft um
we run a large number of services in the
cloud we're very concerned about how
efficient these data centers are um and
it's you know one of the key factors
that we consider when we're designing
equipment for the data center um and so
over the last couple of decades you know
we've been able to sort of rely on
improving processor Technologies to
increase the efficiency of our data
centers that's sort of tapering off and
we have to start looking at other ways
of finding efficiencies for our data
centers
services and you know this is a graph
that shows up fairly commonly in
architecture conferences but basically
what it's showing is as we move from
general purpose processors shown on the
left to sort of more dedicated uh
Hardware with you know as6 like Martha
talked about in her introduction um we
can get significant performance
improvements from 10x to 100x or even
more and so the the key Point here is
that you know we can increase our data
center efficiency by increasing Hardware
specialization
but at a company like Microsoft um we
have a couple of additional challenges
that we have to deal with in the data
center uh when you run services at these
scales um we've pushed updates out to
our software regularly software changes
at least monthly if not more the
machines that we buy last several years
and they're purchased on a rolling basis
so we can have six or more generations
of machines active in the data center at
the same time and a lot of these
machines are repurposed halfway through
their life cycle so they might start out
running Bing code but then they end up
running Skype or some other service that
Microsoft cares about and because we
have so many machines it's really hard
to go out there and do maintenance on
these machines we can't just drop in
additional Hardware if we decide we want
a different Asic in the in the hardware
so homogeneity is highly desirable um in
our data centers so we're sort of left
with a paradox right we want this
specialization that we can get by you
know building as6 and specializing our
Hardware but we also want the homogenous
80 so that we can run all of our
services um on any of these machines
that we
buy so you know if we go back to this
graph the right side is as6 um left side
is general purpose processors and in the
middle we think there's space for a
number of fpga based accelerators and
these trade off some of the efficiency
um but at the cost of or with the
benefit of allowing us to actually adapt
the hardware that we're deploying and
change it as software Services change so
if we look at an example um if we have
you know a server that gets purchased by
Bing uh this sort of gives you an idea
of the spectrum of you know Zeon CPUs
give us a lot of flexibility any
software that we push out we can change
as the software changes on the right
side we have very specialized Hardware
like a network interface this is
something you know we're willing to put
Nicks in all of our machines because
obviously we need network connectivity
uh but in the middle there's space for
putting accelerators in these servers um
so we have two options right we can
build a search accelerator using an fpga
gives us reasonably good efficiency um
and flexibility or we can build it on an
Asic uh but you know if Bing decides
later to change their algorithms a
little what happens well that Asic
becomes either totally or partly
redundant now is just sitting in our
server it's wasting power um and it's
holding back the software from making
the changes that it really needs to and
if later on we even roll a server over
to a different service you know that ack
is definitely wasting power now it's not
actually doing anything for this new
service uh but if we had an fpga in
there we could actually push out an
entirely different accelerator and make
use of that resource in the servers so
you know we believe that there's a lot
of space here to basically build
accelerators on fbgs to give us some
benefits so when we started this project
we had sort of two simple design
requirements uh the first is let's build
some specialized Hardware using a nice
general purpose fpga fabric um but also
let's keep our servers homogeneous uh in
terms turns out you know if we're
throwing stuff into our data centers we
actually have a few extra requirements
that get tacked on uh the first is you
know don't add too much cost to the
servers we have to stay under about 30%
of the the cost of the blades uh the
second is we can't add significant power
draw to the servers uh you know our data
centers are provisioned for a certain
amount of power per blade we're given
about 25 watts to power whatever
accelerators we want to put in there and
finally you know obviously don't break
anything we have to work with the
existing servers we're not redesigning
the Hardware around this new accelerator
we can't modify the networks uh we can't
increase the hardware failure rate so
really you know it's these very simple
uh constraints in the middle but there's
a lot of other stuff that gets piled on
on top of
it so the data center servers that uh
Microsoft uses are these open compute
blades um we released the designs
publicly basically they're one new half
wide servers I have an example of one up
here that you're welcome to come and
check out later um but basically there's
enough space at the back of this blade
for a tiny little uh accelerator card
and this is a pcie gen 3 device and we
basically squeezed an fpga into that
spot uh and so these you know these
blades have Zeon processors healthy
amount of dam hard drives and ssds and
one of the nice things is all the
cabling is attached to a back plane at
the back of the server so if you do have
to do maintenance you don't actually
have to unable everything and plug it
all back together and so the PJ sits at
the back and you know another constraint
that we ended up with here is we're
actually sitting at the back of the
server after all the air has been heated
up by the hard drives and the CPUs and
so basically by the time it gets to us
uh it's really not very cold anymore so
we have to be very careful about how we
can properly cool these fpgas in these
devices it's just something you don't
necessarily think about when you're
initially designing it um so we're using
a fairly high-end uh stratx 5 fpga it's
got about 173,000 alms um as I said it's
PCI gen 3 there's 8 gigs of D on the
board itself uh and it occupies a PCI
slot and draws its power from there and
one of the design decisions we made uh
with this device is to actually build a
dedicated tourist Network to connect all
of these fpgas together and one of the
motivations for that um is that we want
these homogeneous servers we WR we don't
want to have to build a box put a bunch
of
fpjsangprobinsyano that dedicated device
from each of the servers um so if we put
one in each fpga about 48 of those in a
half rack um and then we can connect all
of these with a 6x8 Taurus and that
gives us a very low latency Network to
talk between fpj and allows us to scale
out uh services that might need more
resources than just one
fpga so if we look at how a fabric of
fpga Might interface um and give you
some more motivation for why we need a
dedicated Network um you know if we take
a bunch of CPUs and attach a bunch of
fpgas via PCI Express if we have a
service that Maps across four of these
fpgas we actually you know if we want to
talk between them we end up going up and
down through this software stack and as
Thomas just told us you know going
through the CPU and that networking
stack is actually pretty expensive um so
if we change this and actually build a
dedicated Network between the fpj we can
reduce that latency down to just a
couple hundred NS per hop um and it
makes it much easier to map our Pipeline
on top of that and we can also fit a lot
of other data center Services onto this
fabric if we want to and you know
depending on what resources they require
they can use different numbers of
fpgas so another challenge with uh using
fpgas at a company like Microsoft is how
do we make these devices actually uh
approachable and you know make
development for them slightly easier and
one of these is one of the ways we've
done this this is to essentially include
all of the io and the management tasks
into what we call a shell um and then we
isolate all of the application logic
into a role and the role has a very
simple fifo interface for moving data
into and out of it um and that allows us
to direct traffic to the other fpgas and
the Taurus as well as to the PCI Express
uh cor to get to the host or to the dram
controllers and you know with these
applications we picked a fairly easy one
to start with which is actually
accelerating Bing ranking maybe just a
little sarcasm there but basically if we
look closer at Bing ranking uh it's
actually divided up into two key
components the first is what we call
selection as a service and this is the
part of the service that actually takes
your query and our large document index
and selects a number of those documents
to be ranked uh and to present a final
score um so these are basically
documents that contain all of your
keywords that sort of match what the
intent of your query was um and those
get sent over to the ranking half of the
pipeline and these are basic the ranking
side essentially computes a score for
each document that says this page is
this relevant to your query and then you
take those final scores you sort them
and that's how you get the 10 links that
end up on your homepage or on your Bing
search page um and so we actually looked
at accelerating this whole ranking half
of the pipeline uh on fpgas and so it's
broken down into three distinct uh
stages the first is called feature
extraction and in feature extraction
we'll take your query and a copy of the
page and calculate a number of what we
call Dynamic features about this page so
for example how many times does the
first query word appear on this page in
this case fpga shows up seven times um
similarly second query word we can do
the same thing or how many times do the
pair of words show up next to each other
on the
page in all there's about 4,000 of these
Dynamic features that we're calculating
um depending on the query in the page
and things like that um and all of those
features get sent from the feature
extraction stage onto the free form
expression calculations and this
essentially allows us to take uh
arbitrary computations based on these
Dynamic uh values and uh these are all
sort of complex floating Point math
operations that we're doing um so we can
calculate and we plug all these
variables in we end up with you know a
number for each of these free form
expressions and those get sent down into
a machine learning scoring stage uh at
the end of the pipeline which I actually
can't talk about today um but if we look
a little bit closer at sort of how these
are implemented we can see why we're
getting a significant win uh on the fpga
based versus what we can do on the CPU
so for feature extraction I said you
know there's roughly 4,000 of these
features um there spread over about 200
different families of of features and
those are implemented in about 54
different state machines inside the fpga
so we take the streaming document coming
in and we feed it into all of these
State machines and we process them in
parallel and that allows us to cut down
the processing time to about four
microseconds from roughly 600 on the
software side um so this is obviously a
pretty big win and then all of these
results get forwarded over to the free
form expressions and these are
implemented as a number of soft soft
core processors on the fpga so there's
actually about four Hardware threads per
core um they Implement log divide and
you know a number of floating Point
operations and each six of these cores
all share a complex unit and we do uh
some scheduling to B basically make sure
they can all share that safely and on
each fpj we can fit about 10 of these
clusters or about 240 Hardware threads
so there's a lot of parallelism that
we're getting in the fpga that just
wasn't there or wasn't available to get
on the
CPUs uh so if we take all these
components and we stick them together
into a pip P line uh basically we have
one feature extraction fpga three uh
three of the ffe uh blocks and then the
machine learning scoring at the end and
you'll notice that we have an eighth fpj
at the bottom that's actually a spare
and we use this for fult tolerance which
I'll which I'll talk about in a minute
but to do to actually accelerate this
ranking pipeline we take documents from
all of the servers hosting these fpgs
and allow them to inject at any point in
the pipeline and the request will get
injected passed up to the top of the the
pipeline and then moved all the way down
through the pipeline the final score is
produced and then sent back to the
server that injected it and these all
happen in parallel um and basically
because the servers just see that it's
connection to the fabric they don't have
to be aware of what all the other fpgs
are doing in the pipeline all of that
routing is taken care of on our Taurus
Network so like I said there's some
challenges um to basically making this
work at scale uh in a distributed Manner
and basically you know with the pipeline
formations like this one of the big
things we have to be able to do is map
around fpgas that have failed so you
know if fpga 2 suddenly goes out maybe
its power supply fails or something like
that we actually need to be able to
shift this pipeline around that fpga
basically route around it in the Taurus
uh to be able to deal with that fault
tolerance um there are also a number of
General issues that we deal with um with
fpga Fabrics in the data center um
essentially you know we have this
problem where if PCI device goes away
while you're using it on the uh bus we
need to be able to handle that robustly
and basically reconfigure the fpgas um
we have to deal with ion strikes if our
configuration bits in the fpga get
scrambled due to um you know random
particle strikes we have to use seu
scrubbing single event upset scrubbing
to deal with that um and there's also
integration time when these things are
first delivered there's a huge number of
problems with making sure they're
actually wired up correctly and doing
all the checks that are required
there so we've actually deployed 1,600
of these uh catapult boards uh in a
production Data Center and we've run uh
bing traffic through these devices um so
this is pretty cool and uh you know the
this graph gives you a idea of the
performance benefits that uh fpga
accelerators can get in the data center
um so this is looking at the 95th
percentile query latency versus
throughput so the x-axis is latency
normalized and the queries per second on
the access is normalized the Blue Line
represents our software only performance
running Bing uh Bing's ranker and the
Orange Line represents the performance
with software with the additional fpj
accelerator and so if you look at the
the 0.11 on the software line if we
decide that we want to maintain sort of
constant latency we can actually double
the throughput in terms of number of
documents per second that we can handle
U by adding the fpj or we can decide to
keep the same throughput and basically
reduce latency by about 29%
uh and we've managed to do all of this
while maintaining all of those
constraints that we set out at the
beginning Which is less than 30% cost
less than 25 watts of extra power um
we've seen basically no Hardware
failures in terms of like board failures
and things like that uh since we've
deployed these so we're pretty confident
in the robustness of the solution and
our ability to scale this
up so um in conclusion here i' just like
to say you know we we think that
Hardware specialization is uh a very
good way increasing efficiency in the
data centers it may be the way to
increase efficiency in the data center
um and we've found that an fpga fabric
is really a good way of offering a
flexible elastic pool of resources to
accelerate Services um we've shown that
with B ranking uh we can sort of reduce
the number of machines that we would
need to implement uh data center
Services by half um while maintaining
lower variants in terms of latency
offering lower latencies and we've
proven the scalability and resilience of
these devices uh and there's obviously
huge potential for future applications
uh that to be accelerated with these
devices um but the real question that we
get asked a lot is so when is an fpga
going to start handling my Bing uh web
search and the answer is um you know
this isn't a toy Bing has made a
production uh commitment to take these
devices into production so sort of early
next year uh we'll actually have fpj's
handling fair share of our uh bing web
searches so uh the final takeaway here
is I you know we're I think we're moving
from a model where we have programmable
software running on fixed Hardware
devices to something more like a
programmable software and programmable
Hardware deployed in our data centers so
this is pretty exciting um obviously
this is work done by a lot of people a
few of them in the picture there there's
a bunch that aren't in the picture um
and with that I'd be happy to take any
questions let's thank the
speaker
uh I don't remember who came up first so
why don't we do just go in that
order very nice talk thank you do you
have any Lumber about utilization of fpj
like are they always always running busy
or they're like 50% idle time Idol um so
I mean it depends a lot on the the
workload so some of our stages are
actually faster than others um but sort
of in terms of logic utilization uh
we're pretty much using all of the the
resources there right but the what the
fpg being busy all the time is that is
that busy all the time or still like so
right now basically you dedicate fpj to
one server right so I asked the question
to see if there any potential for
sharing one fpg among multiple servers
so that's why I ask this question sure
um I think the the answer to that is at
the moment switching between Services is
fairly expensive um and because we're
actually using all the resour sources
for that one service um it's it's fairly
challenging to sort of time share the
fpgs in that sense um at larger time
scales certainly I think there's
opportunity right like you know web
search traffic is very cyclical during
the day there's a lot more searching
than happens at night so you could
reduce the number of fpgas that are
running that service and run other
workloads um but sort of when these
services are running they're fairly well
occupied right we're thanks so let's do
the two back there the those up
first thank you very much I wanted to
ask you about the the um software versus
fpga firmware configuration development
debugging stabilizing I mean we have a
lot of experience of turning software
very quickly and when you move to the
fpga that makes it more complicated
wonder if you could speak to how you
work that into your software pipeline
sure um so certainly at the moment uh
the hardware development is a little bit
more challenging um you know
we we're definitely pushing um for sort
of higher level synthesis tools you know
I talked about those 50 state machines
that sort of implement the the various
features in this implementation those
were all sort of written by hand um and
sort of verified independently um but I
think there's a lot of room there for
taking you know they're they're actually
Rel atively simple kernels that we're
implementing um so there is a lot of
potential there for developing sort of
higher level synthesis tools that could
tackle a lot of that um but certainly at
the moment the the hardware development
Cycle takes a little bit longer um but
you know it's sort of one of the prices
that you're paying for the increased
efficiency that we can
get back back there there was one
question I I think you mentioned the uh
free form expression with was pretty uh
FPU dominated y um and fpga generally
aren't known for doing a good job with
floating Point operations so I guess I'm
wondering are there other substrates
that you would prefer to use for that
part of the pipeline
or what are your thoughts on that um so
you know I I will say fbj are generally
moving in the direction of supporting
more floating Point um so I think you
know that's certainly true at the moment
uh but as we go forward I think we're
going to see sort of more floating Point
support um the other thing is when we
did this we were basically given the
requirement that our scores would match
exactly with the software implementation
um and there's obviously a lot of room
here for taking floating point and
turning it into fixed point and sort of
optimizing there and you know as we move
into production with this that's going
to obviously be something we're looking
at there's a question up
here and then I think we'll take the
last one back there
there I'm I'm interested in a Apples to
Apples comparison when it comes to uh
investment in Hardware because clearly
you you invest much more in Hardware so
you could have taken the same investment
and and buy larger servers many more
processors so the question is if you
look at it from this angle and and it's
not clear to me what would be proper
Apples to Apples pons I'm that's part of
my question but if you look at it from
this angle are you really getting ahead
and and if yes but how much sure so you
know the question is basically if we you
know if we just took the money and
bought more servers would we end up
better off overall um and I think the
the answer to that is that you know uh
we can get more out of the fpgas for
certain computations then the the CPUs
would be able to achieve sort of for the
same power and and cost number num um I
think the the point is you have to
balance sort of how much compute you're
putting on GPU or on CPUs versus you
know what you're putting on the
fpgas um and you know I don't know
exactly what the right Apples to Apples
comparison is um but I think that
there's there's definitely benefit to to
spending some of the money on different
types of computation than just general
purpose
CPUs does that make sense I think
there's one last question and we'll
conclude
right thanks for the talk um you had
made some sort of parenthetical comment
at the beginning of your talk about how
a GPU wouldn't fit into that for Factor
it wouldn't fit into that power budget
um was that ever a real consideration
where you were looking at gpus running
um or supporting search in some way
um I so I don't actually know if the
group looked
at search on gpus um it's certainly a
discussion that's been happening uh you
know around Microsoft research and
things like that is like you know what's
the right accelerator technology um but
you know there there's computation that
um fpgas can do that gpus can't um and
certainly with G with fpga moving
towards more floating Point computations
um there sold you know the benefits of
doing GPU versus fpga are sort of
eroding a little bit
um in terms of that computation so I
think you
know I'm not sure that we did look
explicitly at ranking on gpus but we did
okay Jim was here before I was
so um but
yeah okay so let's uh let's give
Applause again for our
speaker